helga s way but i 1 heinrich vom film
learning vom des channel thank you for
what you today is katarina witt
oblicore autoblog chain technologies
freddys introductory video or posted
couple of days ago
die fuhrhand posted link here and top
class click continuously directed to the
sections again  xserve mails and blogs
and technology will link down below
the description like to learn more about
the more you consensus mechanism the
consensus mechanism in the this
foundations priestly level main
blogs workouts foundations building
blocks the indignant as a lecturer about
distributed consensus distribute consensus
sauce really important topic to
learn about you want you to the because the
islands autoblog chain recently directly
into what would like to start with two
contrasts once more centralized
systems the central systems live-blog
chains and realize system is the system
weather report and industries link which
some kaindorf central  instance an
example bie  rbank think about how you in
the bank goldbank it is simple
personnel cover count and facility
transactions was bank at green beck with
inge transaction dispose where is about
tourism bank is in the loft
everything that happens
you can the site selection of the
wellington is the office on dispute that  one piste
princess of play station of the tigers north
wave then invested the step into it
mx have no resolution to the dispute
of the bus ride the central system lag
bitcoin the color blocking works
default loves the is no strings and
released institution of the site
selection center north course
rathaus systems operate and son des bag
significant number of very important
questions to be listening when designing
distributed system live blog chain man
on the screens is the distributor who
learns the block chain is one way of
distributed to large number of
individuals responsible for making the
get up to date employees of no doubt
the sec and passion moo  dy's fitch
transactions and now imagine the case of
the currency and you with from section to
that bird and uplay with somebody else's
trends for us-hilfe kind im auto iv
coins especially display module contains
the network place in new york from section announces
it applies  in vanity case of pop
local cs of course the question of
des up in the air is who can create new
cars the last kristiina all this none
of meta level rules decided to die
salts can change this will also be the
system of thermal baths do that in the evening
this questions the just for me suffers
the poor service consensus needs to
be something and place consensus
mechanism for singles consensus
between the individual notes and can
the system is the site who is right in
what happens somebody who wants to do
something network
because of  course the wild consensus
mechanism is way to different consensus
mechanisms out there in the world on
block chain used by peak times of
blogs chains a b  under the danube is at the
ventoux can the bmz overview quick over
you are the most important once and go
into the thai lady ex delicious first
of work and second of two the stake the
cost of this do mechanisms apropos love
most important and the most watch element
ones up to  date is over you know that
started cooper works of workers probably
the most guideline and consensus basin
must the kosovos introduced bei
bitcoin because on kost bitcoin something
like the godfather blog change on over
to come in peace and justice disclaimer
begin the mainly the snacks
action story  that the smi to bed very
very technical an album not going to
get level of technical review got
lively you are usg the intuition that
helps you understand how things work &
travel simplify your senses before give you
ready to go back to work out of work  by
the basic edition is nice us in not
can whether tim contribute computing power
to the network in der do in the help
network to run n go fo  r work means that
there's not the confi good moore
computing power could about
marseille in the network in darkness
in the case of bitcoin networks the way
to continue could paul because the
protests have no
supervisor can say on cryptography kassel the uniserv
interview one that's all that  passe and
more computing power you could fit hayo
charts is conditional because if
you're the one who will survive the
right to compose the next blog on
concessions network because we have not
scared of the belief that the sections of
all the world of blogs added to  the block
chain and some point of the future
politicians then need the ex blog post
private bro say you have and network a
bitcoin of a true pop relax traffic light you
sings in the download ready
in the last hamburger coins
green the duel with models automotive to
date is proof  of state instead of
using the computing power factor beko
holding on the individual
grade burgheims europe networ  k the chargers of
you be the one who can coupons and extras
action network europe millimeters that
it at the kaindorf lottery system at you
get more tickets georg reul too violently
on course the hjs apparently in
vilnius can but girls decisions internet
word to copy lexa pizzarro list  from you
can be paid services ex take that now
that consensus mechanism interviews at
new economic movement rem is proof of
information
important and decision to be made who
the time to the next of the vision center
network based under network activity
center reputation becomes so simple in the network
put to use for you to the network
to say you have lower level of use from
es ist die thermen certain factors ndm
the popstar interviews the proof of
mechanism the chapel of the real
coop watch out the active dancer in
it's one of them are one of the best
distinctive about jazz or
project management klosters lectura to date
the no one single consensus mechanisms
general i believe the a  ctive noise block
chains connector from joyces the pending
and what is important to them and
problems der voerder pro b in the future
new consensus mechanisms will rise
will help built so far consensus
mechanisms so commands on consensus
madison it is quickly and delivering
the fighting for  searching for the very
best mechanism of the matted not on
the individual applications that
jugend want to built this lecture focus
on the proof of work consensus radisson
mgv like going to match the board of work
work that first recap further in need
for something like consensus mechanism
der  Consensus is grumbling whose
fundamentals wants to the question what
will be the next wave blog on the blog
chain and i think about you have to
obtain a new york times on my
accounts on open concessions also
at rudi seitz what next block is
going to  be
1 of course econsense around this
question everybody internet world needs
to understand integrated blog  into the net
let's go into this one level modi tires
understand that's a bitter
systematic who wants so that's it partly
version of the box chain so that the
major release on the blog is missing
transaction data that have killed in the
past the next web blog needs  to be
selected the block is fundamentals a
collection of transactions because
herford wanted exactly business one to post a
transaction network the
bitkom network somebody money yukos the
transaction tube bitcoin blog chain and
destruction lens in something the
existing bitkom community memory pool of Cortez was built last
from the pool konz is the
open to connections posted on the block
c network at the north in front of the car
the world is talking about the need to be included
in the fish blog damage was still
blocked so took a fight from the pics
including sections which are currently
floating  around in the pool einecke
gateway to the next blog berlin ots the
post to next blog to blog chain manager
computi  ng against a 3 in order to post
one blog blog change of course only one
blog can be the next blog overcast league
counts at home the switch meine
ristorante gesthuysen to publish
textblock in order for business of
workers and play can on the
police post blog meine show  together with him
value of the cross if you get together
with all the block im plaster producers
value the third world war so business
something the sokol träsch may fit
mine compete with each other
in order to serve the rest
fun and my first serve / basel is
so wandered post  blocked
understanding with promotes the puzzle
so that to visualize the complete
range of values ​​of the fashion can take
them back up the contact to the section of the
introduced to watch or grayling sessions
functions take what you have you can
pretend impotent watch
because the summit should output before  the
input value bets session locates the range
of that used to be the complete range
of values ​​of the hash franken granted  if
the rag know the fans concreted path
of fashion would be considered value
is open to the last detail andrei bett des
trash or well you drive me to come up
with mesh output asset value below the
threshold of bees defined health inc
beckert is a block of ice change the
world with the different blogs in the change
the use of concessions complete edit
the middle block steenblock chain the
rossmann valuev pectoral cross of a cross
it stands for non sense of the protein
cssd intrinsic value except form of a
nedic enemy to bed together with the
content of the block the coat post  of the
content, including the potent,
the output on the hash function of
felt the quarters on the wave that the
weed here but no phase which of the
the concert and wave world both
network this basically then almost
too good for my service three
pilots lots of difference values  in
order to come up mother can
total output management and smaller
ranger world can  it is on course
difficult to modify kilt is from my
to come up to finding value creation
date
so the film can rule whatever works of data
center combo cng output
the costly an time consuming to produce
in order to find you me too good for
train  ocelot slots on the earlier news
in order to come up with that is applies
the story easy to verify city of the
valley already help my nobel peace
foundation post the blog business value
to block chain industry you can before the
downloads in the network the band
is  now that's big waves in the blogs
is in the next blog on the block
chain services main subject works rubs
or my second chance at an
ad together to section data display
novels blog the very first of my
programs is a copy of the wave blog
because there can't be any postings blocked
network and a selective sexual buck
at the expense of the ndr is what people i
know that we would people.com the segway
investor yvette computin  g power weekend
amount of computing power in order to
differ block i chose this one to compose
is youtube the production of incentives
as well as block chains is it at none for
the center systems
[music]
what's up to hold the first no double
jumping daddies colt blocked  so mean
or is his spd competitor marc
betz in the word when the both single can't
wait until the beatles from bitcoin at
the moment so that the gockel word is the
second time of reward including
transactions of you use your connection
to the very cool  tour de menu pool4tool
missed - then pick up the sections
incoming middle block june copies of
section 4 vordermayer topic york of
section of works morales live
marketplace mean and candy selfridges
action sci monti cup a blog of course
the national my pick up dust
connections first the film  the highest
end action pointed such user you can set
your own connection pointed at the
expense of sharks the almost places section ruby ​​process
both  networking events you in the late
night of the soul course that actually
sea wolf the time the specific bitkom
lures chaney cross of course bitcoin is
prominent use of work consensus findings
a setup innovate blocks
a monster block time is the time that
the network takes between er  in the blog so
avery ten minutes of the new blog is
added to the block like what we talk to
girls twelve points five bitcoins so
mean rest is dem can hike should
/ matching texts explore the block
chain saves meeting point five bitcoin
ends of course very significant birth
at the time of me recording the video
and $1000 so hits
$500,000
ribery significantly mount importance of
information the johnnie to be the office
betfair bitcoin blocked award hafs
every two hundred and 1000 blogs and as
one blog tech support tcs proximity
talks on travel begin the blog award
for no feininger excel block 15 the
bitcoins end of the harvey proximity every
in front of her
that is then turned city of that caught
at work and nothing to keep in mind or
and bitcoin is bitcoin like carry trades
of difficulty on mastered suitable
present in the course of my so of course de
moor computing power is interviews at
a network the cripo in  order to self
the hash passe the cosmo computers
know in parallels difference 19 user to
come up with one more thing paul-josef
the faster you'll be able to save the
people and for business is necessary to
the difficulty on the hash basel
the table  blog time of ten minutes for
one blog internet core network every
2006 team blog smits proximity fortin
days or two weeks the bitkom network
embrace the difficulty in order to make
sure blocked moritz match race around
ten minutes of the lectura
focus online author network is proof  of
state consensus findings of the doors
fan block chain school of the problem
of justice castile thinks as the
problem is the problem is that needs to
be next blo  gger race to be next blocked
the selective blog cnet
is the consensus of sitting not what
the next block is going to be and
chief consensus is building the ex blog
and collections for the time there and the ex
blog also box title how it works
with which is  probably the most common
the profile poppeller consensus note
that at the moment an abba concert
madison the gaming murder fiction is
proof of state of the very close to
implement call for steak meanwhile so called
caspar update in the very short feature
so irrelevant consensus mechanism so
it gets hot like go away from mine always
something to invest huge amount of
computing power is in order to find that
have no fashion output of the segway
from dead a focus is more and jusos
investing circus of art and lets
in some kind of staff in the  networking
to be able to be the one to send to
compose the next blog the best way
last media the skyliners and day one
to become park on the consense
beke  nntnis order to get ready to lock up
but found help the network ins
have no virtual safe locker so the
service the day the locomotive in response to
be able to use them for certain of time
out of time is still on course larry rivers
in implementation  the
individual blog james vaupel f
committed to the concert
findings from hamm kaindorf lottery mechanism
comes to play
lottery matic mechanism to the one of
them are used to be the one who can
trust his blog ends the motto the
extent randomly at the textile count that
means  built on the individual holdings of the
community leader locked up in order to
participate in the mecca concert of the
lottery and nature rating it is
in my no contribute you can
ticket to ride and more tickets to at
the expense of the chartis but for youtube in
the man you pay  what you get even have
lots of tickets because it's
no guarantee elsewhere at the wn the
euroleague game in sobibór ticket
booklet hayo fans dahe  r your stage cruiser steak
therefore your steak bj chance to be the one
that is because india of the electropop
austin new block in the just want to
mention bkw has then it is not a
simplified view of proof of state works
most implementation that no formation
complex mechanics  are wolf tendence out of
self-defense like bett the lawson software
reactions lots of different
implementation service kastrati
implemented it on 1
different things that is it no
get dominator the basic and
vision you need to understand in order to
understand what does is all about that
being  that way with somebody meet your
stage as well as advantage ascent was still
known jazz is going to get the much more
energy efficient sony pictures is called
blog chains like bitcoin for use energy
consumption moments get
network is put the consumer energy
and some small countries should still have it in
extreme  is remembered
concert in the giant forest consumes so
much energy but mine  he fans with
just have a huge amount of computer
science computer rex features private
computing power power in order to save
the most economical cosimo computing power to
invest internetworld.de york giants of
saving the next block in the hjs is
also the word blocked by gelting
which  significant sbf draw
so hidden that a torment of computing
power and the
computing power of the
interview proof of workers of state and
solutions is looking for a pill that
is problematic was still running in the cloister courtyard the blog award for
mito was built - is a detail as
pointed out in bitcoin  network networks
using proof of work the blog the water
knows such hot tricks is the cost
of the net income edit before the decimal point
and on computing power eco city
the network is because of energy and
utility costs of the hyper-v steak of the
blog awards and tobias heim  and
finally separate centralization risk is
support bhs buffer for control units
mining funds in funkwerk you can
cont  roller network because that the risk of the
central station of the network
economy course big guests the
central is aspect on block chain of
cost well-known arguments pro foster's
death proof of state movement and you
don't have a second no that's then
no one controller the networks and
related  to the people to ever survive
the possibility to design
the head of the notary but finke
built two chambers and max and
contributions to get in interviews
network in order to lend in blogs or
time network impossible before the
notorious consensus is google to
koblenz documentation expedition
consensus  maquet israelis on about you
took some video also the video
press like button in the four
us tourists update something like that know of
course it outside learning technologies
blog jenson button cheers up to date
thank you this is heinrich von learning